in this video I want to summarize the
control mechanisms of prokaryotic
transcription so there are usually two
categories when you that you consider
when you think about how a system is
controlled so the first one is whether
or not it's inducible or repressible the
second if is if it's positively or
negatively controlled we've talked about
inducible or repressible before and that
tells you about the overall system as
far as transcription whether it's
occurring or not so an inducible system
can be turned on so that means it's
normally off a repressible system it can
be turned off so it's normally on that's
something we've talked about before but
what about positively or negatively
controls that we haven't mentioned yet
this tells you the kind of regulatory
protein that is initially made and used
by the operon so if something is
positively controlled it encodes for an
inducer and if something is negatively
controlled it encodes for a repressor we
haven't talked about inducer proteins
but we have talked about repressor
proteins now let's look at this chart
below and try to figure things out so on
the top here I've written whether the
system is negatively controlled or
positively controlled on the side here
I've reducible a repressible system so
this first one is an inducible system
that is negatively controlled so let's
go through and think about what's going
on here so the fact that it's negatively
controlled means that it encodes for a
repressor protein the fact that it's
inducible means that it can be turned on
so let's think about this here normally
the system is off transcription is off
but it can be turned on that that
information comes from the fact that we
know that it's inducible can be turned
on normally off in fact that it's
negative be controlled tells us that it
encodes for and has a repressor protein
so now let's think about these questions
here so normally is the repressor bound
and active well normally the system is
off so would the repressor be bound
normally the answer is yes so this this
system creates a repressor and that
repressor is initially active normally
active so it'll go through bind the
operator and stop transcription now how
can the system be turned on well we add
a co inducer or an inducer so the
inducer binds the repressor on the
operator causing it to fall off and that
makes the repressor inactive so here
I've represented the inducer or the Co
inducer in green binding the repressor
making it inactive a system that we're
familiar with it's like this an example
is the Lac operon which we talked about
in another video now what if we have a
repressible system that's negatively
controlled so this here a repressible
system that's negatively controlled so
the fact that it's repressible tells us
that it can be turned off and that it's
normally on the fact that is negatively
controlled right it's negatively
controlled means that it encodes and how
it goes for and has a repressor protein
so here it's encoding for a repressor
protein now normally is that repressor
protein bound and active well we know
that normally it's on so would it
normally be repressed no that means
initially that this repressor that they
make is inactive so how do we get this
repressor to work how does how is a
system turned off we add a co-repressor
so this inactive repressor protein needs
a co-repressor in order to become active
and then it actually binds the operator
then it stops or turns off transcription
an example of this is the tryptophan
operon that we talked about in a
previous video
now what about a system that is
inducible but positively controlled so
inducible means let me scroll this down
there we go
inducible tells us that normally it's
off normally off and can be turned on
positively controlled tells us that it
goes for and has an inducer protein so
here initially codes for and makes an
inducer protein now normally is the
inducer bound and active well we know
that normally it's off
so the inducer would not be bound so the
answer here is no I actually don't think
I wrote it down here right normally is
the repressor Brown the answer here was
no sorry about that
so here normally is the inducer Brown
well we know that normally it's off so
it's not induced normally it's normally
not bound the inducer is normally
inactive so how do we turn it on we add
a co inducer something to help it induce
so now this inducer is active it can go
through and bind the operator and when
it does the RNA polymerase can go
through so this is sort of activating
things in the way it's going an example
of this is the v idea of catabolized
pression that we talked about in a
previous video right the nikko inducer
was the cyclic AMP II cap complex now
what about our
simple system that is positively
controlled so if it's a repressible
system that means it can be turned off
and that it's normally on so and then
the fact that we know that it's
positively controlled means that it
encodes for and has an inducer protein
now we want to ask ourselves normally is
the inducer bound and active well
normally the system is on so should the
inducer be bound and active normally yes
it should be so the inducer that is made
here is normally active and binds the
operator and RNA polymerase can go all
out of transcription to occur how do you
turn this off well you add a code
repressor or some sort of repressor that
causes that binds to the inducer making
it inactive an example of this either
next we didn't actually talk about one
so I'm going to put here example none
that we talked about I'm sure there are
some but this is just sort of a general
idea for all these four things I hope
that video was helpful in explaining
these control mechanisms is that in a
sort of overview fashion one last thing
I am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email I move University at gmail.com and
see the description below for more
details thanks for watching